>> Greg: HAPPY MONDAY,
EVERYONE.
I HOPE YOU HAD A GLORIOUS
WEEKEND.
I WAS IN SALT LAKE CITY, UTAH.
FANTASTIC PEOPLE PURE HERE'S MY
FRIENDS HAVING A TYPICAL
SATURDAY NIGHT OUT TWO.
♪♪
THAT LOOK LIKE JASON CHAVE IT'S.
SPEAKING OF LAZY.
LAZY RIVER.
THE SITES OF PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
NUMBERS ARE LOOKING UP.
AS YOU ARE LOOKING UP FOR MY
BOTTOMLESS PIT IN.
SAY HELLO TWO TED KENNEDY.
ACCORDING TO CBS NEWS POLL, MOS
AMERICANS BELIEVE THINGS ARE
GOING BADLY UNDER DISTRACTED AN
INCOMPETENT BIDEN.
NEARLY EIGHT IN TEN SAY SOME
THINGS ARE GOING VERY BADLY.
NOW BRING UP HARRISON, GETTING
YOUR FACE GETTING EATEN BY A
CHIMP GETS BETTER REVIEWS PIERC
SCIENCE, SPEAKING OF CHIMPS,
WE'VE GOT A NEW CONCERN IT IS
CALLED MONKEYPOX.
IT IS KIND OF GROSS, ACTUALLY
PIT ACCORDING TO THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION OF THIS
DISEASE IS BEING SPREAD BY AT
RAVES IN EUROPE.
SO JUST BE SAFE, NO RAVES FOR ME
.
IN EUROPE.
DEFINITELY NO MAC WITH MONKEYS
AT LEAST FOR TWO WEEKS.
YOU'VE GOT THE FLAT THE MET
CURVE AND IT IS SHAPED LIKE A
BANANA.
GET IT OUT OF MY SYSTEM.
WERE GOING TO BE COVERING A LOT
OF MONKEYPOX.
IS NOT SPREADING HERE, I THINK.
>> THIS WHOLE MONKEYPOX VIRUS I
COMPLETELY OVERBLOWN.
HERE ONE AT THE LAB IS FOR --
PERFECTLY FINE.
NO PLOT.
BACK TO THE POLLS HERE NEARLY 50
% THINK THE ECONOMY IS FAIRLY
OR VERY BAD AND 56 DISAPPROVE
HOW BIDEN IS DOING HIS JOB IF
THE ELECTION WERE HELD TODAY HE
WOULD BE IN BED AT NOON.
ALRIGHT, FAIR ENOUGH, YOU DIDN'
LAUGH.
IT'S OKAY.
THAT IS AN HOUR EARLIER THAN
NORMAL.
65% SAY THAT ONE IMPORTANT
THINGS COME UP, BIDEN IS SLOW T
ACT UNLESS IT IS A STOCK TIP
FROM HUNTER.
40% OF DEMOCRATS FEEL THE SAME
WAY.
WE ASPECT PRESIDENT BIDEN IF WE
THOUGHT HE WAS SLOW TO ACT AND
HE REPLIED THURSDAY, WHICH
WASN'T ANSWER TO A QUESTION FRO
TWO WEEKS AGO 35% BELIEVE BIDEN
ADDRESSES PROBLEMS RIGHT AWAY
WHEN DID HE BUY THOSE PEOPLE?
IT NEVER GETS OLD.
WHEN ASKED TO DESCRIBE THEIR
FEELINGS ABOUT THE STATE OF THE
COUNTRY, MOST PEOPLE USE BRAZEN
LIKE UNEASY OR WORRYING.
IT'S ALSO FRUSTRATING, WHICH IS
HOW, HARRIS DESCRIBES READING.
ODDLY 11% SAY THE STATE OF THE
COUNTRY WAS CALM AND ANOTHER 7%
SAID INSPIRING.
INSPIRING, ARE YOU KIDDING ME.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE!
THERE IS SOMETHING DECEPTIVE
GOING ON HERE.
INVITED US LOOKED AT, ESPECIALL
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MAJOR
CRISES LIKE INFLATION, CRIME,
THE BORDER, BABY FORMULA,
DAVIDSON EMBARKING ON A FILM
CAREER APPEARS HE'S GOING TO
HELP YOU MOVE APARTMENTS BUT
SHOWS UP AFTER THE WORK IS DONE
JUST TO EAT THE FREE PIZZA.
IN BIDEN'S AMERICA NOBODY WOULD
END UP GETTING PIZZA BECAUSE TH
DELIVERY DRIVER WOULD BE
HIJACKED AND SHOT ON THE WAY.
NOWHERE TO BE SEEN, EXCEPT WHEN
IT IS TOO LATE TO DO WONDER WHA
JOE HAS GOT TO SAY.
>> NO, NO.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT I'VE DONE
THIS BEFORE?
YOU WANT TO TALK TOUGH WITH JOE?
THIS IS NOT MY FIRST RODEO.
I'VE BEEN ON THIS DANCE FLOOR
BEFORE.
YOU PUT YOUR RIGHT FOOT AND, YO
PUT YOUR LEFT FOOT IN, YOU PUT
YOUR RIGHT FOOT IN AND YOU SHAK
IT ALL ABOUT YOU DO THE HOKEY
POKEY.
COME ON, MAN, THAT IS WHAT IT I
ALL ABOUT.
[APPLAUSE]
WE ASK THAT YOU SAVE THE
APPLAUSE UNTIL ALL THE AWARDS
ARE GIVEN BEING SLOW TO ACT, IS
THAT THE CASE ALL THE TIME?
JOE THINKS HE.
>> FAST WHEN IT SERVES ITS OWN
AGENDA.
HE UNLEASHED A MOMENT HE TOOK
OFFICE IF YOU BOUGHT GAS OR
INSOLENT RECENTLY, YOU DO, BUT
THAT WAS THE POINT APPEARED HIS
ELECTION WASN'T ABOUT DOING
SOMETHING, BUT UNDOING SOMETHING
, ERASING THE PREVIOUS
FOUR YEARS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
OR HIS PRESIDENCY HAS BEEN LIKE
AN EPISODE OF FLIP THIS HOUSE
APPEARED THE DEMO OF THE KITCHE
IS WAY EASIER THAN BUILDING A
NEW ONE, ONLY HE DIDN'T REPLACE
THE KITCHEN WITH ANYTHING AT AL
EXCEPT FOR THE CORN POPS STORY
AND HE SHOWED HIM THERE'S OTHER
PLACES WHERE HE ACTED WITH
LIGHTNING SPEED, CUTIE --
ACCUSING THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND THEY DIDN'T EVEN WAI
FOR THE FACT BEFORE HE SPEARED
HIM.
HE CALLED HIM A WHITE
SUPREMACIST AND IT TURNS OUT TH
ONLY THING JOE SHOULD BE
PRESIDENT OF IS CNN.
THINK ABOUT OPPORTUNITY WHERE H
COULD BUY THE COUNTRY AND
LABELED THEM RACIST, HE ACTS
FAST, DEPENDING ON WHAT HUNTER
HAS WITH HIM.
SO WHEN WE SAY THAT BIDEN IS TH
SLOW WALKING DISASTER, WE ONLY
WISH THAT WAS THE CASE HE
ACTUALLY DOES BAD THINGS
SUPERFAST.
ONE MINUTE HE IS A JOHN AND THE
NEXT HE IS FLESH EATING BACTERIA
.
HE WAS ABLE TO DESTROY A COUNTR
THAT WAS DOING JUST FINE WHEN H
TURN OVER --
TOOK OVER IN JUST MONTHS.
HE REPLACEMENT GETTING US IN --
DOMESTICALLY HE'S A
DOUBLE-BARRELED DISASTER THE
EMPTINESS IS UNTIL BY AN
OPPORTUNISTIC ADVENTURE HERE
HE'S LIKE A NEWBORN CHILD
ADOPTED BY THE MANSON FAMILY.
HE ISN'T MERELY A PRESIDENT, HE
HAS A HOST, A HOST TO A
PARASITIC DISEASE THAT INFECTED
HIS PARTY AND OUR INSTITUTIONS,
SO WE'VE GOT TO LOCALIZE HIS
INFECTION AND FORGET MONKEYPOX
JOE IS THE MONKEY.
IF HE INVITES YOU TO A RAVE,
DON'T GO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
IT MIGHT POKE YOUR EYE OUT JUST
BY LOOKING AT HER, THE AUTHOR O
THE NEW BOOK HERE'S THE DEAL
KELLY AND CONWAY.
HE'S EVEN SMALL --
SMART SMARTER THAN HIS ACCENT
MAKES IT SOUND DOUGLAS MURRAY.
HE IS SO --
A MECHANICAL BULL TRIES TO WRIT
HIM.
AND FINALLY AND FOR CATNIP, SHE
IS SO SOUTHERN SHE SWEATS
MOONSHINE, DAGEN McDOWELL.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK.
>> IT'S A DOOR STOPPER.
>> HEAD IT IS, AND A DOOR
STOPPER JUST LIKE YOUR OUTFIT
TODAY.
YOU ARE LIKE A SHINY PENNY IF I
WAS WORTH SOMETHING I AM NOT IN
THE BOOK, BUT THAT IS OKAY.
>> YOU ARE IN THE FAMILY PICTUR
PIERCE SURPRISE.
>> DO YOU THINK WOULD WHEN YOU
LOOK AT WHAT IS GOING ON RIGHT
NOW, DO YOU THINK THAT THIS
WOULD HAVE HAPPEN SO QUICKLY?
>> NO, NOT UNLESS TIME THAT HAS
TWO HAVE A BABY.
>> JOE BIDEN, HOW LOW CAN YOU GO
, JOE, HAS BEEN THE PULLING
CASE FOR HIS PRESIDENCY AND
THERE'S MANY WAYS TO LOOK AT
THESE POLES AND COME UP WITH TH
CONCLUSION THAT.
>> AMERICA ACTUALLY LOOKS PAST
HIM NOW BECAUSE HE HASN'T DONE
COURSE CORRECTION AND SUBURBAN
WOMEN ARE UPSET, MANY OF THE
2020 BOATERS ARE NOT SKEPTICAL
AND THEY WON'T EVEN ADMIT TO
POLLSTERS THAT THEY VOTED FOR
THEM AND HE IS ONLY A DEGREE
HIRE THAN HIS VICE PRESIDENT TO
CRIME NOT DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR ALL OF THE
CLAIMS ABOUT YOUTH THAT ENERGY
AND FREEDOM IN THE FUTURE IS
BEING RUN BY AN OLD ANGRY WHITE
MAN.
>> THAT THE IRONY OF THE WHOLE
THING.
YOU BEING BRITISH, AS ALWAYS,
IT'S LIKE AN ANTIQUE --
>> Shannon: FINALLY YOU ARE
HERE IN A REAL COUNTRY.
>> OH, COME ON.
>> Shannon: --
>> Greg: OUR FURNITURE IS LIKE
--
I LIVED INSIDE A TREE.
I'M A KEEBLER ELF.
IS THAT A TESTAMENT TO THE US
THAT WE CAN ENDURE INCOMPETENT
LEADERSHIP?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE BEST AND I
WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS THE
OTHER DAY.
THE FOUNDERS CREATED A SELF
DRIVING BECAUSE IN WHOEVER'S IN
THE FRONT SEED GENERALLY CAN'T
DESCRIBE IT STEP JOE INVITED A
BUNCH OF CHILDREN TO THE DRIVER
SEED AND THAT IS WHAT WE ARE
DEALING WELL --
DEALING WITH.
>> I WANT TO SPEAK FOR THOUSAND
7% SAY THEY ARE INSPIRED.
WHERE DID YOU GET THOSE PEOPLE?
7% OF THOSE THINK I CAN'T WAIT
FOR TOMORROW.
IT'S SO GREAT, I CAN'T WAIT FOR
THE NEXT --
IT IS SO GOOD.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE THESE
PEOPLE ARE FROM.
>> IN EVERY POPULATION THERE AR
UNSAFE PEOPLE AND THEY TAKE THE
POLLS.
>> HALF YOU EVER PENNED BONE BY
A POLLSTER?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT I'VE HAD
PHONE CALL PERIOD.
GENERALLY PEOPLE DON'T CALL ME.
I DON'T HAVE VERY MANY FRIENDS
BUT I HAVE LEARNED TO LIVE WITH
THAT.
I LIKE TO CONSIDER MYSELF A
LONER, A RECLUSE AND I COLLECT
LOT OF THINGS.
>> YOU COULD UP A PHONE CALL IF
I HAD YOUR NUMBER.
>> NOT ALL FRIENDS AND FAMILY,
IT JUST DOESN'T.
BEFORE DON'T YOU THINK THAT THE
BIG PROBLEMS DON'T BOTHER HIM
BECAUSE HE IS SO OLD AND HE'S
LIKE HOW MUCH TIME DO I HAVE
LEFT.
HE DOESN'T THINK ABOUT US.
HE HAS TO THINK ABOUT GOING HOM
TO EAT JELL-O.
>> I THINK IT SOUNDS DISMISSIVE
AT --
CHOICE ADJECTIVES ARE ABSOLUTEL
CORRECT, OLD AND ANGRY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN FORGIVE
MANY THINGS I THINK THEY CAN
FORGIVE SOME OF THEIR QUALITY O
LIFE THAT THEY'VE GIVEN UP IN
TERMS OF INFLATION AND CRIME BU
THEY CAN'T FORGIVE THE KIND OF
INCOMPETENCE THEY SEE ON THE
PODIUM ON A WEEKLY BASIS AND
THAT WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT --
AND REMINDS ME OF MY 80-YEAR-OL
GRANDPA, HE'S NOT IN CONTROL AN
HE'S NOT GOING TO BE BOSSED
AROUND.
>> Greg: WE LOVE OUR
GRANDFATHERS EATING TAPIOCA
PUDDING.
>> I THINK HIS REACTION IS TO B
AGGRESSIVE AND ANGRY IN THOSE
MOMENTS WHEN HE CAN SHOW SOME
INDEPENDENCE, IT IS I WILL NOT
DO THAT AND THEN HE COMES ACROS
AS ANGRY AND THAT ANGER IS ALSO
UNAPPEALING WHEN COMBINED WITH
INCOMPETENCE BEFORE HE GOES FOR
DRAMATIC EFFECT AND IT COMES
ACROSS AS BIZARRE.
IT IS LIKE ROAD RAGE.
, LOVE FEELS VERY GOOD AND THEN
EVERYBODY IS STARING AT YOU,
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU DON'T EVEN
HAVE A CAR ON THE ROAD.
YOU KNOW, THERE WERE SOME PEOPL
IN THE MEDIA THAT COMPLAINED
THAT JOE IS DOING A GREAT JOB B
EVERY METRIC.
WHAT DO YOU THINK --
WHAT METRIC DO YOU THINK HE IS
DOING?
>> THE ONLY METRIC I CAN THINK
OF THE IS HE IS GOOD AT MAYBE
MAKING PEOPLE FEEL SORRY FOR HI
THE ONLY POSSIBLE STRATEGY AT
THIS POINT COULD BE BEING SO
PITIFUL THAT HE IS DOING THAT
THE KAT PEOPLE TO CUT HIM SOME
SLACK.
YOU LEAVE HIM ALONE.
HE THINKS ELON MUSK IS HIS
WIFE'S PERFUME.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT DOING THIS
DOES NOT WORK.
I WAS WORKING THIS ANGLE IN HIG
SCHOOL TRYING TO GET BOYS TO
SUCK FACE WITH ME JUST OUT UP
YOUR PITY AND IT DOESN'T WORK.
I DISAGREE WITH YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CARRY A GRUDGE
JUST LIKE I DO.
I HAVE GOT A CHAINSAW WITH THIS
GUY'S NAME ON THE SIDE OF IT
DUNKED ME WHEN I WAS IN MY 20s
.
>> WHAT WAS HIS NAME?
>> I'M NOT TELLING.
>> I HAVE TO SAY THIS, I WORRY
ABOUT WHAT SHE JUST SAID I THIN
THERE'S TOO MANY PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S DEFICITS AS I
PRESENT A SECRET SYMPATHY FOR
HIM.
I THINK THAT BARACK OBAMA IS
REALLY RUNNING THE WHITE HOUSE
AT I FEEL BETTER.
TO CREATE SYMPATHY FOR JOE BIDE
IS TO EXCUSE HIM AND I THINK
THIS MAN SHOULD BE MADE TO EAT
EVERY POLICY THAT HE HAS HOISTE
ON OUR SHOULDERS OTHERWISE WE
ARE IS EXCUSING HIS CONDUCT.
YOU LOOK AT THE POLLS AND HE
DOESN'T DO ANYTHING WELL AT THI
POINT.
THEY HAD COVID FOR A WHILE AND
IT'S A JOKE SINCE TRUMP LEFT AN
HE'S BEEN FACING THREE VARIANTS.
IN SPITE OF AT I THINK THAT
POLICY IS NOT TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT THEY CAN ALREADY SEE IT'S
REMINDING THEM THAT THEY CAN'T
SEE AND EVERYBODY CAN SEE THIS
MAN IS FAILING.
EVERYBODY CAN SEE A VICE
PRESIDENT WHO HAS AT THE MOST
INOPPORTUNE TIMES REALLY CAN'T
SPEAK WELL AND PEOPLE DON'T HAV
CONFIDENCE IN HIM.
I WOULDN'T MIND PEOPLE --
WITH THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE GOD
FED THE CHAOS AT THE BORDER AND
THE DRUG DEATHS AND KIDS BEING
TAUGHT TO HATE AMERICA AND EACH
OTHER PICKED IT GOES ON AND ON.
>> AND JUST BE THE FACT THAT WE
MAKE FUN OF A FACT THAT HE'S
EMPTY VESSEL AND WE FORGET WHAT
IS BEING PLACED INSIDE THE
VESSEL WHICH IS A LOT OF THIS
WOKE IDEOLOGY.
WE G